foreign
let's go out to Gretchen in Pittsburgh
what's up Gretchen
hi Dr John this is cool hearing you
through my phone I listen to you all the
time on YouTube it's cool hearing you
through my phone very cool what's up
so my question for you is
um I oh gosh how do I say this I really
hey Gretchen we are way past that on
this show just say whatever I know I
know I
nerve-wracking once
it's not like sex okay
um I I think the word I use is like I
resent it I resent
sex as a whole partially just I think
it's due to a lot of things for me it's
it feels very mandatory
um I also just have this feeling like I
genuinely don't need it I don't want it
um and it's causing issues because I
know my husband needs it I was gonna say
are you married I am married I've been
married for
um about 15 months
and I actually didn't I did not have sex
before marriage I was a virgin when I
got married
um and we kind of didn't anticipate any
issues in in this regard because
granted even in the confines of trying
to remain a virgin before marriage you
know you still you make out and and you
feel a passionate connection towards one
another and then I got married and it
feel like felt like it went away
um and now it's to the point where
I have absolutely no interest in having
sex with my husband at all none
um and I'm not 100 sure why I could
probably come up with a list of possible
reasons but I just and I'm kind of at a
point where I don't really know what to
do about it because I know
well I may not need it I know he needs
it and it's getting very challenging for
me because I'm just kind of in this
please don't touch me I don't want to be
touched I don't I don't feel like this
doing this today and even on the times
that I kind of muster up enough to have
sex with my husband
I mean I enjoy it
once I get there but getting there
is like very hard for me yeah
um and I'm and again I'm at a point
where I like
I don't really know what to do about it
and I want to fix it because I I want to
want to have sex of course but I I don't
excellent well number one thank you for
saying that out loud
I imagine you're not telling a whole
bunch of people that is that fair
no I think I've mentioned it to two
girlfriends okay one agreed with me and
one was like what are you talking about
okay I'm gonna run through so number one
I want you to know you are absolutely
not crazy you're not alone okay
and not alone to the tune of millions
okay so you're not nuts
cool good thank you
um
I'm gonna run through a series of
questions that I always ask folks in
this situation okay
yes
um but before I do that I want to
at first acknowledge
it happens a lot for people who uh
choose to remain a virgin till they're
married
is that sex becomes
to use religious imagery becomes an idol
it becomes a thing that is going to
solve and fix all things
and it's going to be
um
like you probably heard it said in your
religious organization your bodies will
just know what to do and it will just be
this sinking up and this magic whatever
and I'm just I I just don't think that's
accurate
um yeah I'll agree and so there's this
powerful pressure put on it
and not only that as a woman you have
this performance pressure and this
Instagram World pressure that you've got
to compete with fill in the blanks all
those things
um you and your husband or how old are
you
I'm 25. yeah so I was just talking about
this earlier on in the show y'all both
were raised in a culture whether you all
participated or not that was raised
entirely by pornography and so either
the images or the this is what it's
supposed to look like and this is we're
all supposed to be screaming and yelling
and having chaos and it's supposed to be
fun and exciting and the wallpapers are
supposed to fall off the walls on its
own and the house catches on fire that's
the world that we've all that you've
been handed this is what it's supposed
to look like and there's no playbook for
the weird awkward what are you do that
is real sex especially as a couple's
getting to know each other right yeah
there's no and so everything feels like
failure screwing up I don't like this
and depending on our bodies
some of our and this is about experience
this is about genetics this is about a
whole Cascade of things
somebody's respond to failure and to
this isn't working right and this isn't
what looks this was wasn't what my
picture was
they respond to that by running head in
head first into that burning building
they're fire men and women they run
straight in I'm going to solve this
problem let's keep working on it and
other people
get out of the building they shut the
thing down right
so I just want to start this before I
ask you questions like start by
acknowledging man you guys have built a
hell of pressure to live up to right
so number one are you
um
do you have any abuse in your past
no okay
none you can think of or just no all
good I guess I
get a little rougher on the edges and I
think there's some emotional trauma that
comes with that but I wouldn't consider
it abuse okay so it depends on your
definition
okay
um
are you on any sort of birth control
no no just rocking and rolling
uh yeah I learned how to Natural family
plan
um and when doing a lot of my research I
just determined that that was the best
way to go and so far I've had no issues
okay
um and I'm smiling every time someone's
like nah dude we're just we're just
doing it natural builds are always my
friends that ended up with their kids
first but you do you you do you
um okay so and the reason I asked that
is
before I did anything I would go see my
doctor about hormones
okay 100 percent
before you do anything else we have any
more conversations before you go see a
counselor I would have you go get your
hormones checked
um the hormone regulation is all over
the place and depending on what Rabbit
Hole you go down it can be diet related
it can be you know experience related it
can be genetic who cares who it just is
so I would go have all of those things
checked have you done that
I have not okay so that's a good idea
okay I would do that third is your
husband
you love him I know that
is he a jerk or a bully or a
why won't you do this or I want this
um yeah pretty much okay
that has to stop because your body I
know your body's trying to protect you
yeah I
answered this is going to be
tell me about him
um
so
um we met I'm actually originally from
Buffalo I met him when we when I moved
to Pittsburgh when I after I graduated
from college
um and
he is someone who has an addictive
personality he's also incredibly
particular
and
it leads to just like endless nitpicking
about the most ridiculously little
things some of it seems
unnecessary a lot of the times
um I deal with it I have a pretty thick
skin so you know I kind of let it roll
off my back I think the problem is is
that it doesn't really roll on my back
nope and then it manifests in other ways
like this vessel van nikolk wrote the
book and in the title of the book is the
body keeps the score
yeah you can be tough Buffalo gal all
day long and Buffalo Gals are tough make
no mistake right
um but
I your body might say oh you're not
leaving okay cool we're shutting the
system down
yeah I think that's what's been going on
and a lot of times especially new
couples
with and again I say this with all due
respect and if he was on the phone I
would say this to him directly okay
um
he can have a quote unquote addictive
personality or he can have OCD or he can
have ads he can have all these things
he can also be an ass
right
yeah so you can have all that stuff
great that's a context it's not an
excuse to be disrespectful to your wife
it's not an excuse to not help create an
environment where she feels her body
feels safe enough to be sexual
and nitpicking and one of them hey man
why are you wearing that oh my gosh you
need to lose five pounds all that crap
like that's creating a world that sex
becomes it it's a place that sex
intimacy can't inhabit because the world
is so toxic
and here's what often happens you become
his mom
you start taking over responsibility for
making sure he feels okay
and it's really hard to have sex with
your kids
yeah I think I think for me it's
actually more the other way of like it
be like having sex with my dad because I
spent most of my childhood
kind of again playing into making sure
that my dad stays calm or quiet or
whatever and I think this feels very
similar okay um and so instead of like
necessarily your kid it feels more like
very it's very similar to my childhood
yeah okay there we go so
um here's here's your
here's your path forward okay and I'm
gonna tell you is is can you be real
honest with me
sure uh is he abusive
no
emotionally
I don't let him be emotionally abusive
that sounds really tough and cool and I
appreciate you uh flexing is he
emotionally abusive
I don't know I really don't know if I
can answer that like I
sometimes
let me put it struggling to say yes
because I don't really want to say yes
because I don't know if I could
I don't want to say yes okay I will
leave you to deal with your reality but
you know the truth
you also know that guys can wrap
themselves up and I'm a good guy and
they can be hyper abusive without ever
saying a word
their presence can hover around a home
like a grizzly bear
and when you ask them dude what's wrong
well you just when I'm wrong you're like
driving me crazy because you always
nitpicking me I'm just sitting here
watching TV bullcrap dude that whole
thing was a flex just as much as if
someone was yelling and screaming and
smashing glasses up against the wall
it's just a slow nuclear reactor burn
and if you grew up with that in your
home your body knows you better
disappear kid
right
yeah it it puts a like peacemaking
filter on because that's what I did as a
child I was The Peacemaker of the
household right and so then that becomes
the priority of how do we end the
conflict and I will say I am sometimes
equally as guilty as being explosive
sure but it takes me
I think a lot longer to get there than
it does
and he's not explosive and angry it's
just
the criticism is never ending right
so here's what y'all are in desperate
need of number one before today's over I
want you to make a doctor's appointment
to go get all of your hormone levels
checked okay it's gonna cost money it's
gonna be a pain in the butt go get it
done okay even if nothing else you're 25
it'd be a great Baseline to have as you
get older okay
second thing is you all need to call a
marriage counselor today
and if he won't go
tell them we have to learn how to
communicate because I'm not safe in this
marriage anymore
my body's shutting itself down
and I've got to find a different way to
live
I want you to come with me
and when you go to counseling you are
going to have to risk him getting up and
walking out
with your honesty by saying things like
I'm not safe with you here or you I've
you've got to stop criticizing me
because I can't stand before you with no
clothes on and say do you love me if
you're always criticizing me criticizing
me and criticizing me and blaming me I
can't do that
he's got to hear that from you and it
sounds like he is not safe enough or or
that would be a smart conversation for
you to have by yourself so you need to
go get a counselor and have that
conversation
but what I'm telling you overall is you
take drastic action and again we can
talk about uh asexual and people who
just have no sex drive that's a whole
other conversation the last thing I want
you to do get emelina gotsky's book come
as you are ordered on Amazon today
and I want y'all to read it together
Emily nigotsky's come as you are read it
together and it will be awkward for
y'all to read together I get it
but it will give you all a new language
and a new way to have this conversation
about how do we create a world where my
body feels safe enough that sex becomes
exciting and fun
and what role are you husband gonna play
in helping me co-create that context
that world that environment that
ecosystem
go get that book today have us into your
house and you'll read it together
thank you so much for your trust and man
we will be rooting you on anytime you
want to call give me a shout we'll be
here